usual accomplishment because social
scientists are a group that don't take
casually any form of agreement and so
the fact that he's been able to wrangle
that level of agreement from this group
is quite striking the reason that social
scientists degree on Malcolm Gladwell is
he gets the science right and that's a
key issue for social scientists that's
why we spend hours reading our
colleagues dense awful academic prose
and trying to help them shape it in a
more appropriate direction it's why we
ourselves in our own research might
spend three or four or five years
writing a tightly written as much as we
can do 30 page paper that might be read
by at most one hundred people across the
world okay but it's also why when we get
a call from a journalist there's a
little bit of trepidation there because
we care very much about getting things
right and many journalists don't have
malcolm skill about doing that now to be
fair it's a very difficult task to take
a field or to even take one of these 30
page papers and condense it down into a
500 word or less article but it's also
why social scientists when they confront
this situation of talking to a
journalist worry deeply about whether
this is going to be one of those
situations where somebody gets the
science wrong now what that means is
it's a credit to Malcolm Gladwell as a
thinker and a writer that he's become
the kind of Good Housekeeping Seal of
Approval for social scientists we can be
comfortable reading about our field
reading about other people's fields
because we know that underneath the
beautiful stylish prose the science has
been done justice now everything that
I've just said explains why Malcolm
Gladwell's New Yorker columns for years
are exchanged with enthusiasm and
reverence among social scientists
equivalent of junior high school kids
passing around autographed baseballs but
with the tipping point he's gone way
beyond that he's taken a notoriously
difficult subject social fashion social
movements revolutions and he's provided
some useful guidance about how and why
they happen and so if I think about this
little book I think of it is kind of the
Palm Pilot of of science writing its
it's especially like the palm five that
really elegant stylish version of the
palm this is is small it's very
high-tech it's stylish and it quickly
becomes such a part of your life that
you don't know what it would be like not
to have had it in the first place so my
sense is most of you who are here
tonight have read this book and that's
why you're here but for those of you
that haven't you have a treat in store
for you Malcolm Gladwell will give you
some very simple principles the law of
the few the power of context the
stickiness factor that will help you
understand an important phenomena in the
world like why Hush Puppies came back
from the fashion graveyard or why Sesame
Street is a beautiful education program
but Blue's Clues may actually be better
or what graffiti has to do with violent
crime in New York City or why Paul
Revere was the ideal person to take a
midnight ride and start the American
Revolution let's welcome Malcolm
Gladwell
thank you that was a very generous
introduction I don't usually get
introductions that generous I'm very
happy to be here I is very nice to be in
a size like this where I feel like I've
known because I often you know I
sometimes give talks in you know places
like Palm Springs too big conventions in
fact I gave one recently and I I was
walking to give my talk it's one of
those big hotels on a golf course and
the hotel this big u-shaped
driveway and I was walking across the
driveway in order to give my talk and
some guy pulls up in a car and emotions
towards me
and so you know being a friendly sort I
actually went to see why he was
motioning towards me and he handed me
his keys and he said I'll need them back
at four o'clock which just made me you
know was a little bit of a disquieting
experience although the tip was very
good but it is an explanation about why
I'm so much more happy to be in a
situation like this I thought I would
talk a little bit about my book and then
talk a little bit about about things
that have occurred to me since I wrote
the book since I'm assuming some of you
are familiar with it and I wanted to
sort of talk about um the phenomenon of
the social epidemic but what that means
because it's something that is sort of
is the one part of the book that's kind
of stayed with me and and continue to
kind of puzzle and interest me I tell
the story in the book of for example of
this kid called Seema this teenager
consumer who lived in Micronesia and is
this very sad story about a kid use it
like I say he was 70 and he was staying
with his family at his grandfather's
house he gets into a fight with his
father his father asked him to get
something from the store and he didn't
do it his father gets very angry at him
in Gales at him in a way that father's
yellow 17-year old boys and tells him to
you know get out of here find somewhere
else to live so Seema leaves the house
and he was quite upset and he sees his
brother and he borrows a pen from his
brother and he keeps walking and a
couple hours later his brother gets
concerned and wonders where Seema is
gone and tries to retrace his brother
step
goes back to their house their family
house but which is one town over and
looks through the window of the living
room and he sees Seema hanging by the
noose around his neck dead he's
committed suicide as a little suicide
note he's written next to his body which
says basically you know it's a very sad
day for me but it's a happy day for a
pas who's sent me away and that's sort
of a horrible story and it's a weird
story because people aren't supposed to
commit suicide over their fathers
yelling at them like that but the truth
is it in in micronesia it's not an
unusual story at all Micronesia has had
this very strange experience with
suicide there was no suicide to speak of
on those islands until the 60s and then
at some point in the 60s a very
charismatic young man who was the sign
of a prominent family gets into a love
triangle he falls in love with two women
he actually bears a child but both of
them follows a child with both of them
and doesn't know what to do is so
disrupt that he commits suicide and his
funeral is this sort of very dramatic
event that's attended by all people from
all over the island and at the funeral
that two women meet each other for the
first time and they both faint on the
grave it's a kind of thing that really
makes an impact on and after that
funeral the suicide rate among teens
begins to rise in Micronesia and over
the years it rises and rises and then it
really takes off to the point where by
the 1980s suicide rate in Micronesia is
the highest in the world and to give you
a sense of how high it is in this
country we have a very serious problem
with teen suicide and our rate is
considered to be unacceptably high
teenage suicide in my ratings Micronesia
in the 1980s was seven times the
American rate and at that level the
notion of a kid committing suicide
because his father yelled at him was not
unusual kids committed suicide for the
most seemingly trivial of reasons they
were committing suicide because his
parents don't give him enough money for
beer another case because someone's
brother he yells at him says he's making
too much noise another case a kid sees
his girlfriend with another boy and
commits suicide it becomes sort of part
of the culture becomes something that
people do for the most sort of trivial
reasons not only
it becomes a kind of ritualized part of
the culture everyone commits suicide in
very much the same way
it's invariably unmarried boys in their
teens living at home have a domestic
argument of parents or girlfriend or
brother it almost always happens on the
weekend at night after drinking and they
take an empty room they always write a
suicide note is never about kind of
despair it's all about a kind of wounded
pride they all even use the noose in the
same distinctive way they are
self-consciously in other words
copycatting from previous suicides now I
tell that's during the book because to
me is this really interesting and fast
an example of a social epidemic you've
got a case of a one person who does
something seemingly isolated but does
something in a very dramatic way and it
begins to spread from there that example
hops from him to someone else into
someone else into someone else and then
you've got the method of transmission
you know it's not a rational method it
isn't that kids in Micronesia saw that
guy commit suicide and said to himself I
want to be like that guy it was that it
was a kind of involuntary process it was
it was as if they were infected by this
idea and somehow that infection changed
the way they thought about the world it
altered it in some way that didn't
really make rational sense it was
involuntary and it was non rational now
I think that that if you compare that to
the way that we get something like you
know the flu when you when the flu comes
every winter you don't ask to be
infected by the flu but you just get
infected and when you get infected it
fundamentally changes the way you think
about the world right it completely
you're on your back you're unhappy
you're you know now what is the
difference between the way the flu
spreads and the way the suicide virus
spread in Micronesia I don't think there
really is a difference I think that we
are talking about fundamentally
analogous processes and that's really
the point of my book which is to examine
that kind of phenomenon this notion that
an idea can travel in the same pathways
as a virus now I tell that story in the
book specifically because I'm interested
in examined
the process of teenage smoking in this
country which I think is fundamentally
similar to the Micronesians suicide
epidemic it is a self-destructive
behavior which spreads I think through
largely non rational involuntary I don't
think kids in this country want to kill
themselves solely with cigarettes I
think they get caught up in this
particular ritualized mode of expression
in the same way that kids in micronesia
did but you know there are all kinds of
manifestations of this my favorite
example recent example was the Belgian
coke poisoning scary I don't know if any
of you remember this summer of 1999 all
these kids in Belgium at a high school
42 kids start get sick they start
vomiting and I have to be hospitalized
because they've drunk some tainted coke
and the next day in the town over same
thing happens a couple dozen kids get
very very sick and it goes from town to
town through Belgium until over 100 kids
end up being hospitalized and this is
the remember this is a huge deal
remember those stories in the paper Koch
has is incredible black I share price
drops you know eventually the CEO has to
resign for a number of other reasons but
among them is this sense that he has
badly mishandled
this whole poisoning scare and they do a
little research and it turns out that
the bottling plant in Antwerp had
contaminated in the contamination in the
carbonation process and so it's you know
opening a shot case of food poisoning
essentially how about if that's what you
were what we were told when you read the
media accounts of the Belgium coke scare
well it turns out that story is a lot
more complicated the first thing is that
coke sends the tainted coca-cola to a
lab to be analyzed and they say sure
enough there is something in the coke
that shouldn't be there these sulfides
and the sulfides you know what you know
what sulfur smells like it's like rotten
eggs so we have the explanation of why
this thing was so pungent but they only
find the sulfides at a level of five
parts per billion now you cannot get
sick from five parts per billion of
sulfides it is impossible you in order
to get sick you need about a thousand
times more of these sulfur contaminants
all that can happen at five parts per
billion is that you wrinkle your nose
and you turn away right so puzzle number
one
is why were kids getting sick when there
wasn't enough of this content in there
to make them sick then the Belgian
government starts to do a little
epidemiology and they start they take
all these kids who were hospitalized and
they start retracing what happened to
them during the day right well it turns
out that well over half the kids didn't
actually drink coke that day they drank
Pepsi and in the summer 1999 there was
nothing wrong with Pepsi Cola in Belgium
so now we have two puzzles we have
something that should not have been
making kids sick making them sick and
then another group of kids who were
getting sick when they didn't even come
close to the supposed agent right so we
have a very different phenomenon here
now what is going on well clearly what's
making these kids sick is not something
in the coke it is the idea of something
in the coke now the important thing to
remember about this is that the symptoms
they had were real they weren't making
them up in the sense that they were
faking it they actually were sick they
did need to be hospitalized it's just
that the reason for their sickness was
not an actual biological agent it was an
idea now I think that that is a truly
important and critical point and I
actually wrote this little piece of The
New Yorker about at night I call up this
guy in England who says I'm an expert on
this kind of phenomena which is known as
a hysterical epidemic and he told me
that the minute he heard this guy named
David Wesley or Simon Wesley he said the
minute I heard that you know there was
something wrong with coke and Belgium he
bets a case of champagne with the guy
across the hall from him that he would
turn out that there was nothing wrong
with the coke and the reason he was so
sure is that it turns out there have
been hundreds of examples of this kind
of phenomenon over the last couple
hundred years that it's actually quite
common that not common but reasonably
common that these sorts of there was one
in England in 1919 80s there was a
similar incident at a jazz concert where
a whole number of teenagers got very
very ill and they blamed it on
pesticides didn't nearby field in turns
out there was no pesticide they were
simply and the way it works is he
explained is if you know there's one
person who is not feeling well and they
are drinking something or smelling
something or they can just be become
convinced that something
environment is the reason they're not
feeling well two years ago would be an
evil spirit if you are at that jazz
concert it's the pesticide if you're in
Belgium it's the coke and then they get
a little more more anxious because of
this thing they think is poisoning them
and they they get a little nauseous and
because they get nauseous they get dizzy
then because they're dizzy they start to
hyperventilate because they prevent
elate they faint
well the persons sitting standing next
to them looks at this person fainting
and realizes they had two minutes before
said I think it's something in the coke
and they start to get a little anxious
because they get anxious they start to
get a little dizzy and because they get
dizzy they didn't get nauseous them
because they get nauseous they
hyperventilate because they're hyper
they're like they faint and all of us
said you've got two people fainting
everyone else in the room is looking at
them and getting nauseous and dizzy and
hyperventilating and fainting and soon
enough of course the whole room is
fainted and is on the way to the
hospital I love that story in in in many
ways because it it's this wonderful
example of the power of ideas but also
because it's fundamentally
counterintuitive you know it turns out
to be surprisingly hard to convince
people that this the cause of this kind
of phenomenon is entirely up here and
not in the can of coke I I did that
story this um a woman who rides a media
column for the Village Voice called me
up and was questioning me about it and
we spent two and a half hours on the
phone and she led me through it I try to
explain to her the data and like you
know this historical phenomenon she
could read this book and this book well
the article comes out in the Village
Voice the next you know we you know
Gladwell
thinks the kids made it up you know you
know Bjork were once again chills for a
big business or whatever her particular
you know which is you know it's like I
don't even drink coke I have no you know
taking a commitment to the coca-cola
company but um you know she just
couldn't grasp this notion you know
which on the face of it is it's sort of
it's it's a little ridiculous that we
can't dropped it I mean what does it
mean after all to be in love when you
are in love you have physical symptoms
your heart races your pulse gets your
hands get clammy or you can't sleep
you're feverish right but you're not
there's nothing wrong with you there's
no virus as infected you you are you
have been infected by the idea of some
and we have that is a similar kind of
phenomenal ideas can have these
extraordinarily tangible effects you
know another good example of the same
phenomena I think is Columbine you know
look at what happened after Columbine if
over the following 18 months there was
something like 19 instance of school
violence in this country
many of those were nipped in the bud and
actually happened but they were you know
either they happened or they were just
caught this before they happen if you
examine the case histories of those 19
incidents what you will find is that
there is an extraordinarily ritualized
element to each of them they are self
conscious reenactments of the Columbine
tragedy the kids are what are wearing
the long trench coats they're mentioning
Columbine obsessively in their letters
they're aping the kind of missives of
Klebold and Harris said Harrison this is
a this is a precise reenactment of the
Columbine tragedy by other kids now the
reason why I think that's an important
point is that when people are trying to
account for school violence what do they
say they say well this is an example of
the rising tide of violence in society
as a whole well you know what it's not
schools are actually safer today than
they have been in the last 25 the number
of kids who get hurt in the school
setting is declining steadily schools
are safe places there is not a rising
tide of violence in the schools right so
we're talking about something that is
not hooked into some larger social
phenomenon the other thing people say is
well this is an example of the
alienation and isolation of the American
teenager well you know teenagers as far
as I can tell have always been alienated
and isolated if he went back to being
read you know the accounts of the
teenagers of Sparta I'm sure they would
say that you know our major problem as a
society is that the teenagers of Sparta
are alienated and isolated it is a
condition of teenagehood
to be a lated and isolated right the
difference is that through most of human
history a alienated Knights that the
teenagers did not take out their
alienation and isolation on their peers
with automatic semi-automatic weapons
the difference in Essex
other words is not some kind of global
shift in the behavior of teenagers it is
that there is a specific infection that
dates from a specific incident that has
proved to be enormous ly contagious and
enormous ly powerful in altering over
some period of time the outlook and the
mindset of a particular group of
troubled kids it is in many ways I think
precisely similar to what happened in
Micronesia in their suicide epidemic and
precisely similar in some ways to what
happened in Belgium with their coca
epidemic now these are all examples of
of sort of their sad examples they're
not happy examples my book is not a is a
happy book not a sad book i'd like to
divide books into two categories and my
point in the book though is that you
know we're very familiar with these kind
of horrible kind of epidemic but you
know these epidemics also are the
explanation for why good ideas spread
and that you know when you're when you
are marketing something I don't just
mean a product I mean a behavior a
social change any kind of of if you have
any kind of social agenda when you look
at something that is very that is very
very successful as often is not what you
see are some of these same principles at
play you know the example that comes to
mind is um seatbelts seatbelts the
seatbelt story in this country um and I
wrote a long sort of needlessly
provocative article on this The New
Yorker the seatbelt story in this
country is actually quite fascinating
you know through the 70s and 80s early
eighties seatbelt use is below 15% in
this country it's going nowhere and
people are trying all kinds of
techniques nothing is happening
and then in the middle of the 1980s over
a span of a couple of years it just
shoots up it goes up to 65% in a space
of a couple of years if you talk to
people who study kind of social change
of in the kind of public health arena
they will tell you that they have never
in their lifetime seen a dramatic scene
a chant a social change like that that
happened so quickly and
so dramatically now why did that happen
well we can come up with all kinds of
reasons seatbelt laws all kinds of but
the to me the interesting thing is that
once that change happened it was
permanent that it became a kind of habit
right that every time you sat in the car
you just put on your seat but after that
and you won't go back there won't be a
time when you don't use your safe
anymore it's become a kind of engrained
it's not rational or voluntary anymore
it's just become a kind of part of the
way we use the automobile that is to me
sounds to me very much like a kind of
epidemic change a change that's
analogous to the kind of evidence I've
been talking about particularly when you
think about how quickly it happened no
the thing that is so striking about all
of these epidemic changes is the speed
and the once you by passing rational
channels things are happening like that
and that's why the seatbelt thing to me
seems to fit into that category
because you would think particularly in
this country that if you wanted to get
people to change their behavior in a way
that would make a broader social sense
it would take some time I mean least
that's our experience with but in this
case it just sort of happens is if by
magic overnight and I think that's the
same this kind of epidemic process is it
is it is clearly to explain it um it's
another question and then all I will I
won't talk for long's because the
question answers all was much more fun
but there's not a great example of this
or this or this raises another question
to me which is an interesting one which
is how does this kind of infection
this contagiousness work because I think
you know when we talk about social
change we tend to spend a lot of time
thinking and talking about mass media
about the effect of advertising and the
effect of traditional forms of
communication but what to me is really
interesting about these cases that I've
talked about about Belgium about
Micronesia and even about seat belts in
large part is how much um those kinds of
traditional forms of of communication
don't play a role what we are talking
about is really direct face-to-face
contact we really are talking about
things ideas passing in the same
way that virus is passing that viruses
past I mean what is it that made the
Belgian coke example so potent for
example it was not that kids at
neighboring towns you know if I had if
this was 1979 and I said to you
are you aware right now that there's a
serious problem with coke and if you've
had a coke in the last day I'd be very
concerned we would not have an epidemic
of people getting nauseous dizzy and I
prevent letting and fainting you kind of
have to be there when the person next to
you having just said I think there's
something wrong with my coke collapses
that has to you know you've got to see
it for that bit real infection to take
root the same thing with with micronesia
i you know i don't think that these kids
were could have randomly reading about
what had happened at that funeral and
were sort of applying this lesson in
their own life i think that they knew
people who had killed themselves in this
precise way and they were they they were
infected because of how close and
personal that to the point of contagion
was and that's something that that kind
of face-to-face contact i think is is
enormous ly important in explaining the
particular power of these kinds of
epidemics there's a great example this
which is what linguists refer to as
uptalk which is the valley girl speak
it's the practice of ending a
declarative sentence in a formal
question right it's what every teenager
sounds like this is a topic that's
actually of enormous interest to
linguists and they've spent a huge
amount of time trying to figure out
where up talk comes from because you
know
linguists have these tapes they've been
making for 80 years or whatever of the
way Americans speak all over the country
and if you listen to the tapes
you don't hear up talk until I think the
70s so there was this huge attempt made
in the United Nations to figure out
where it came from and if you go to all
the tapes in the West what you discover
is that up talk probably starts in
Australia in the 1960s maybe New Zealand
public Australia
and somehow it makes its way to North
America now there was a huge effort to
figure out well how did it get here
and the first culprit of course was mass
media there must have been a movie or a
show or some and a suspicion of this I
think was it's probably because of
people had seen the effect of Saturday
Night Live on what people call
linguistic innovations the emphatic not
you know don't go there these are all
kind of Saturday Night Live isms but the
interesting thing about Saturday live
isms is that those particular linguistic
epidemics that start because of sorry
I've never last the emphatic nod is
basically dead
don't go there is very close to being on
its last legs what's interesting about
up talk is that up talk has persisted is
it is the epidemic that is kept on going
right and it really is an epidemic if
you think about it teenagers do not when
they are 14 years old or 13 wake up one
day and consciously decide to start
ending declarative sentences in the form
of a question it is an involuntary
process that kind of takes them over
when they hit early adolescence and
infects them through their teenage years
and then leaves them you know kids no
long stop doing it at 20 I don't know
kids
adults when people reach adulthood they
don't not no longer do that anymore so
it is this kind of it's like an extended
bout of measles that begins with so it's
a very interesting question where is
this thing which doesn't need to be
going anywhere we don't see there are
known you look at new generations of
kids they're still using up talk so it's
this really remarkable transformation
how did it happen well after tons and
tons and tons of research there is
absolutely no evidence that up talk
spread through the media you can look
and look a look and you won't find it
it must have spread through face to face
contact somebody came from Australia at
some point in the 1970s and had the
unusual practice of ending declarative
sentences in the form of a question and
this example proved so compelling to the
teenagers of you know Southern
California I suppose maybe originally
that they adopted it and it spread from
there you know and there's all kinds of
you know I think it was some you know
gorgeous 15
old Australian girl whose father was
transferred from the Melbourne office to
the LA office of you know IBM and she
went to Beverly Hills high or something
but actually someone actually recently
told me that there's evidence that it
was probably surfers which makes a lot
of sense
who took it to Hawaii and then from
Hawaii came to California and there's
all kinds of long discussions which if
you want to in the Q&A period we can get
into of why surfing culture would be an
extraordinarily contagious culture to
the spread of particular social
epidemics but all of this is a way of
saying that and I will end on this that
when we think about why certain things
spread and other things don't when we
are trying to account for the unusual
success of certain kinds of ideas I do
think that we need to pay much more
attention to what people are saying to
each other and less attention about what
we are saying we are simply saying to
people that we get a little bit too
caught up in the kind of top-down model
and we've we forget how fundamentally
social the process of behavior change
and idea generation is and that social
process is really what my book is
interested in trying to describe and I
hope if you if you read it um you'll get
some some sense of that way well thank
you very much
so I take questions and become Dan he's
asked most people write about business
using sports page style but you write
about business as if it were a mystery
novel and this leads me to wonder how
many stories you consider at a time so
are you can you take anything and turn
it into a mystery is the question or do
you look over lots of different things
and select the things that that have
that characteristic
oh um what's my hit rate in other words
my head rate is depressingly low at the
moment I've been going to a bad stretch
and many things that I have tried to
make stories out of I have failed and
this was I just finished a 700 page book
which I kept thinking was going to yield
some extraordinary mysterious insight
which would make be the kind of basis of
a story and nothing happened so you do
have to kind of not everything works
although I I always cling optimistically
to the notion that that everything that
if I just think it's my fault if they
don't work and maybe it is I just simply
lack imagination next question is from
sushi Rita GSB class of oh three how did
you persuade your editor to publish a
theoretical book on epidemics and did
you have any idea it would be a
best-seller um I had no idea it would be
my sort of my kink you know when you
write a book I'd never written one
before um you know I just I just hope
that my mother would like it and I wrote
it with her in mind and when she did
like it I gave it to her as a draft I
was I considered my task done and you
know you could argue I suppose that my
mother is a somewhat biased observer of
my writing um but I have chose to
believe that she was this
extraordinarily objective reader and
that if she bet it liked it then that
would mean that others would how did I
convince my tutors to write this book -
well you know there was very little it's
very easy answer that there is very
little um a similarity between the
proposal that you write that you use to
get your book
and the book itself once they've signed
off on the book you know no one's coming
by your office on a monthly basis to
check up see whether you're continuing
to follow the same principles so the
answers you simply lie um and I've
noticed at the New Yorker as well the
same thing I try to keep stories I'm
working on in the dark as much as
possible because once you've presented a
finished product to them there's you
know the wiggle room is particularly you
know if they've got a space all lined up
for it and so you can actually set away
with a lot um if you're interested in
getting away with a lot several people
have asked questions about about how the
book has been positioned by publishers
so did you expect yourself to be you
know billed as a marketing guru and be
asked to consult for corporations when
you wrote a book about social epidemics
no I had no idea we had this long
discussion about whether where it would
go um in the bookstore but I didn't know
and the reason I think it ended up in
the marketing area is that I'm told by
booksellers that you just sell more
books if you put it in the marketing
area which makes me think that if I ever
wrote a novel I want to have it shelled
in the marketing area as well so I might
just you know suckers and people didn't
do it um that was a mystery to me I
don't I I it's very hard to kind of look
you know I try to write in an
interdisciplinary way and so it's very
hard to UM to kind of decide where I
belong if you're going to be I was
reading this thing recently on Melville
Dewey the guy who invented the Dewey
Decimal System
and of course Melville Dewey thought
that there was a place that you could
take all of human knowledge and kind of
divide it into the right he's very
intersting guy I didn't realize for
example he was so obsessed with
efficiency that his name Melville he
changed to spell - he spelled as mal VI
L and also he's responsible he's the
reason why New York freeways are called
thruway's th are UWA why because you
know it's a far more efficient way of
anyway I was thinking you know if Mel
will duly read my book you know a my you
know nine 60.1 you know whatever
category I don't know really what novel
would have said
following up on the theme of business we
have a couple of speculation about
business questions so Denise writes can
you explain the internet bubble as a
social epidemic the ability for everyone
to suspend reality about business models
in order to drive up the price of
Internet companies in fact yes in this
really interesting way I read the study
ones that was interested in when people
communicate online as opposed to
in-person how does that change the
nature of their communication and the
conclusion was that one of the weird
things that happens when you communicate
online is that you end up with a much
more positive impression of the person
you're talking to than if you and the
study which is really wonderful was it
looked at a bunch of people who were in
long distance relationships and one
group were allowed to see each other
over the course of I don't know a year
in person one group we're allowed to
talk on the phone and one group could
only email each other at the end of the
year you asked them well how's it going
how do you think about your partner and
the people who were only allowed to
email were the ones who were happiest
now
you think that's an example of how
wonderful email is in fact it's one
would think that in fact it's not it's
an example of how terrible email is
because the people who were least happy
with each other were the ones who
actually saw each other but that's
because they were dealing with the real
person and that real life is like that
that you deal with when you're online
you're not actually dealing with a real
person you're dealing with this you can
so much to so little information back
from that you're making stuff up and
that the person that you're
corresponding with is in your head
right and of course if you get if you
had the chance to to correspond with
someone in your head you're not going to
make that person unattractive
uninteresting you're going to make that
person to be thrilling and beautiful so
the internet what is this why does this
apply to the unit well the chat rooms
that bit up the stocks of you know of
Internet companies to 700 times earnings
well of course they bid them up to 700
times earnings because if you're
emailing with somebody about something
you're not actually talking about the
real company you're talking with the
company that's in your head which is
infinitely more beautiful and thrilling
than the company in real life I think
it's no accident that those two things
happen at the same time that if a chat
room was actually a chat room that is to
say all of us got together in this room
and chatted about jbs unifies jbs
unifies would not have traded it you
know $300 a share it would have traded
at 13 because when you were actually
dealing with someone a real person
you're forced to deal with information
in all its complexity so I think that
that you know the unit bubble is is in a
certain sense very much the creature of
of which also makes me wonder you know
during the tulip bubble in Holland were
they like frantically sending letters
across town about tulips and we're the
guys who didn't but in fact gathered in
like the cafe to talk were they're the
ones who kind of you know didn't lose
their shirts maybe just a thought
niel more class of 92 is asked since the
time your book was published I'm sure
people have tried to change or reinforce
their types as better mavens or better
connectors what kind of stories have you
heard about people's lives being changed
by the way they type themselves oh well
I don't actually think that my book has
change anyone's life and if it has I
would be terrified I do there are people
who have attempted when they when they
read about these character types they
want to turn themselves into but you
can't do that of course because you know
a connector for example a very very
social person is affected because they
have a kind of gift to be very very
social someone who doesn't have a gift
of being very social and is very very
social is merely annoying so you can't
like you know I I feel II very strong
with it
the great thing about these character
types is that they are innate because
once they were Nate it means that
they're there everywhere you know I had
that little story in a book about people
epidemiologists trying to find the
connectors among the heroin addicts of
Baltimore in attempt to use them to
spread word about better health
practices the reason a lot of stories so
much is it it says that even in a group
possibly the most kind of desolate
bombed out neighborhood in America and a
group of people who could not be more
disadvantaged there are people who have
extraordinary social gifts and the
reason they have that is that you know
these gifts are sprinkled randomly
across the human landscape and they
don't just belong to people who are you
know well educated and wealthy and live
in big houses or a research related
question from Jonah Berger says where do
you think research in this area is going
and what important questions do we need
to better understand to comprehend these
phenomenon oh do I have any thoughts on
where research is going um uh I don't
know I would hate you know you write a
book like this in you um you know I get
very nervous when I think that there
this book might be used as the basis for
you know research cuz what if someone
did research and you know discovered it
was all wrong you know so you know it's
just journalism and I I get a little you
know I mean that might just be a kind of
insecure paranoid vital reaction but you
know there is when you write for a
living and you write lots and lots of
stories as I do you have a kind of
expectation that sometimes you're right
and sometimes you're just going to be
wrong and I have written things that in
retrospect are just wrong I mean I look
back and I kind of wince I have this
because I have all my stories on my
website I sometimes think would anyone
notice if I just took out like you know
or you know removed a not in a sentence
at a critical place so you know maybe
it's just the nervousness unlike a thing
about an academic scientist is you do
fewer things and so you you know you can
be much committee much you can be much
more certain that what you're doing is
substance but um now for the biography
questions of your bribery so several
people have asked how you get started as
a journalist to talk about your history
in your background did you do anything
else before you were a journalist well
as I said earlier to the spunk of people
I was talking to um when I got out of
college I applied to Stanford Business
School and failed to get in so that's
explanation over what and then I then
tried to good job in advertising and I
applied to 21 advertising agencies in
City of Toronto and received 21
projections so I was explicitly rejected
by the world of business which may
explain why I was still we going to
write a book calling into question many
of the practices of American business
and journalism my father had told me as
a child that that he hoped that I would
consider a wide range of possible career
choices but I really shouldn't go into
journalism because it was a terrible
profession so you know I was in the in
the spirit of perversity that informs
nearly all young adult behavior I
decided to become a journalist and I got
very lucky because the Washington Post
where I started out I'm had one
fantastically successful year in the
late 1980s where they hired basically
anyone who walked by their door and
I was it was like one of those sweeps
you know how in England in like the 17th
century when they were trying to get
people to serve in the army they would
just go on one of those sweeps through
neighborhoods and just like round up all
the able-bodied men well the Washington
was bent on a sweep for people who could
write a Stan's a machine and I was I was
I was swept by by the post and
interestingly you know I had never
written a newspaper story before in my
life and in I was working for the
business staff of the Washington Post
which is where they push you if you had
never written a newspaper story before
in your life um because of the
Washington Post of course businesses the
bottom of the totem pole would not be
the case it was New York and my very
first story was an earnings report in a
local company and I had never I didn't
know what earnings were and I said that
the company had lost a million dollars
in the previous quarter when it had in
fact made a million dollars so you know
the next morning the share price
plummets and I received my little lesson
in the power of the media which I never
quite forgot but um the other thing that
I was I don't remember Michael Isikoff
the guy who could have broke the Clinton
scandal well Mike is the coffe sat next
to me when I started the Washington Post
at that time he was reporting the Tammy
Faye Baker Jim Baker sex scandal he also
broke down sir and if you know that and
he was at the time I started the first
my first week attempting to find a
second source for this highly salacious
story about evolving a sexual act and
one of those two characters and I was
like you know I'd never worked in Uzi
before I'm sitting there I didn't know
what to do I was terrified I start there
and for the first week I listened to my
host the cop attempting the second
stores the story and I was like so this
is what the American media is like
it's really quite an introduction again
several people asked questions about how
you select topics for stories how you
decide I mean is there an editor that
tells you you know this would be an
interesting topic to write on how do you
find these unusual quirky things that
you sometimes write about yeah um well I
am I editors don't I try not to get
story of summons because um because then
I feel the editor has too much ownership
of the story and it limits your options
how do I get my story ideas well a lot
of it is you know there are some
motivations that are entirely that are
entirely personal like I was once doing
a story on um hair color was all about
the women who came up with the great
Clairol and L'Oreal hair color campaigns
and um it was a story where there was
one woman named Shirley polikov who came
up with does she or doesn't she only
hear hairdresser knows for sure and then
there was a woman named alone SPECT who
came up with because I'm worth it right
and so that I had this great thing with
Shirley Polikoff and his whole thing
with alone I'll inspect and the story
you know we paid paid by the word and so
you really don't want to ride it spend a
lot of time in a story that doesn't go
for a long time so I had these two women
I don't let's work and I was like I had
like five thousand words I was like
short I said what I'm gonna do so then I
was in this is a long way of answering
the question but I was in the lobby of
mccann-erickson the advertising company
and I was looking through this book
history book they had and there was a
picture of the Christmas party for
McCann Erickson in 1900 52 and it's in
the Waldorf Astoria and everyone's
wearing black tie and keep in mind that
I already had this story where I had
written about two very very remarkable
women in advertising and I look at this
picture and there are a hundred and
fifty people in the picture 149 of them
are men and is one woman so that oh
great
by the solution to my problem so I said
who's this woman they said oh that's
hurt or hurt so
and um I said who's heard of Hertz like
I said oh she was this brilliant
visionary woman she was part of this
whole group of Viennese psychoanalytic
trained people who came to Madison
Avenue in the 50s I said if she's still
alive they said well actually she is she
lives outside of Innsbruck in the Alps
so I said I know it's February
you know I said so I go back to Manor
and I say you know what this story needs
it needs her to Hertzog at this point I
knew nothing about her it's like by the
way so I just took off for the Alps um
to go visit her two Hertzog now what I
didn't know is that her two had recently
had an accident and she was on a kind of
oxygen thing and she couldn't even talk
for about 45 minutes at a time but I
didn't tell my I found this out right
before I was about to go I didn't tell
me out of this so I went flew to Vienna
and drove up into the Alps and you know
all these Austrians were like skiing
next to me is my car skated and I went
to visit her to her side for 45 minutes
and if you read that story you will see
that there is surely polikov there's
although inspect and then there's a
whole thing which randomly drops into
the story for the last 2,000 words which
is all about her - Hertzog and then
there's this heroic attempt made of the
end of story
to link her to Hertzog these other two
women and I have no evidence that she
ever met them thought about them having
to do with hair color it's just I know
and I spent about a month working on
that last you know thousand words to tie
and is even one little line I remember
where I say if her to Hertzog had ever
been in the room with a lone speck and
shuttle bollocky she would have you know
Dada so anyway a long way of saying that
the process of putting together stories
can be highly random and
it's often is also never more fun than
when it's Holi random question is was
Tina Browns run at The New Yorker good
or bad for the magazine um oh it's only
good
Tina was a genius and she remade the
magazine and um um she hired me for
example so I'm not no no no I honestly
think that she did save the magazine and
that David has you know Remnick has sort
of I think very brilliantly built on the
kind of changes and smooth out the edges
and but I mean the magazine is a I think
we owe a huge debt to her all right
back to current events with the recent
fall of corporate Titans subbies
Jeffrey Skilling at in Iran can you
comment on why seemingly successful
well-educated powerful business leaders
would participate in the net achill
behavior um well that's a question
that's slightly outside of my knowledge
I read this really wonderful galleys of
a really wonderful book that's about to
come out called when smart people do
stupid things or something like that I
forgotten that this is wonderful series
of essays describing this very question
and I'm now desperately looked trying to
searching through my memory to remember
some of the observations they made but
the answer is that oh well I'm not
really supposed to talk about my ex but
although I did already I realized but
the answer is that that that is that
just I will say only a very general but
now observation which is the world
wouldn't work unless smart people did
stupid things because then it would be
grossly unfair right because smart
people already make the most money and
you know married the prettiest spouses
and live in the biggest houses if they
also led mistake-free lives then what
would the rest of us do we would it
would be you know life would have no
point um so I think of I find something
strangely self-affirming about the fall
of Enron I'm like you know what it's in
the end you know everything evens out
and
those of us you know who the little
people we can take some solace in the
fact that smart people do screw up
spectacularly all right question is
we've all read your articles with what
books magazines etc do you read for
inspiration and ideas I read a Sports
Illustrated which I've read every issue
cover to cover since 1974 I read a I'm a
recent convert to car magazine which is
this great English magazine about cars
because I'm a car net I read the New
Yorker magazine which I urge all of you
to read as well don't know I couldn't
read a lot of random things I forget
every bad memory so I read lots of um of
those kind of cheesy thrillers in fact
my goal in life is to one day write one
of those cheesy thrillers which is all
plot I just love that notion and nobody
would you know the thing with us if you
write one of those things no one ever
would criticize you for having lousy
character development you know the
minute you sell a book that is you write
a book that is sold in that little rack
in the store and the airport it's like
all bets are off no critic is coming
after you don't you know and I just
think where else in America can you
engage in a creative pursuit where no
one is going to call you on your kind of
failings it's just like it strikes me as
the most of wonderfully freeing activity
creative activity so that's what I
that's what I hope to do one day when
the heat of writing nonfiction yet you
know gets to me but um right practical
questions have you ever tried to start
an epidemic or have been asked to start
one
well I mean I had to sell this book
which um and we did all kinds of things
we actually thought about this a lot
when we were marking the book because I
had done um this I'd done this New
Yorker article about Yaya's sisterhood
and I was very interested in the success
of that book which was a great kind of
classic example of a word-of-mouth
bestseller and I became convinced about
two things one was know I became
convinced about one thing which was that
that book
out of the Pacific Northwest and I
became convinced that the Pacific
Northwest was the kind of seating area
for word-of-mouth book bestsellers so
when my book came out before my book
came out we spent a lot of time me my
publisher in the Pacific Northwest
hanging out with you know book mavens
trying to kind of convince them of you
know the worth of this book and then
when it came out I spent my first sort
of two weeks I just camped out in up the
street um and basically you know it was
him it was impossible to find an
unsigned copy of my book in San
Francisco in the March in March of 2000
fact I expected you know that there
would be you know somebody would come up
with a they would sell for great an
unsightly would sell for some great
amount on eBay
because they would say I have the only I
have discovered the only um because I
know I mean I don't know I mean I
suppose it worked I mean it's impossible
to kind of but I we were happy with the
results um and also you have to hang out
in terms of scope I mean it's a great
even it was wrong I mean what about ruse
you know you're doing to help you're
camped out in like a luxury hotel in San
Francisco for two weeks so the question
is how do you find such interesting
people to talk about and are there any
characteristics that you look for when
you decide who you want to interview for
your articles um well I had these I was
thing only I had these kind of moments
when I'm interested in a kind of person
like I had my middle-aged Jewish woman
moment which lasted about a year and a
half which was actually I should explain
the theory behind that it was actually
done they ended up all being Jewish but
it was really about middle-aged women
journalism is about if you think about
it is about two kinds of people it's
about older men and young women trust me
pick up a magazine and just do a simple
demographic analysis of the people who
are profiled in magazines they are all
women under 30 and men over 50 white men
over 50 this to me is profoundly curious
why we should have removed 50% of the
human population from the auspices of
journalism I don't know so and also I
became American and also what's even on
about [ __ ] about that is do you think
about it who do would you expect
just kind of from the outside looking in
to be the most interesting group of
people in America well if you were like
a Martian you came down with looking for
story ideas I think you would say well
middle-aged women because middle-aged
women over the last if you were born in
1935 as my mother was was she more than
35 32 I forgotten I do the math um you
lived through greater social changes in
your lifetime than almost any member of
a specific generation has lived through
when my mother was born women were not
expected to go to college or you know
amount to anything she is now 70
some-odd years old and women are running
things and taking over the world that's
an extraordinary transformation so if
you were a successful middle-aged woman
in the year 2002 you must be really
really special because you came of age
in the middle of this extraordinary
transformation you would like her to
Hertzog her to hurts like had to be
special because she's the only woman in
the room do you know what she must had
to go through to become the only one in
the room it was like you don't need any
more evidence of some way I said to
myself this is an outrage here all these
wonderful women and no one writes about
them why I don't know because they look
forgotten and they had these great
stories and sure enough you know if I
wanted to I could write about nothing
but middle-aged women till my dying day
because there's an infinite number of
fantastic stories of people who made it
in this credible time um
so sometimes that's my kind of thinking
other times but mostly it's just kind of
random um you know you view you get on
like little Fiat convinced of some minor
fact that it's really about a way of
channeling various obsessions like it's
a good example of well that P side the
needlessly provocative piece I wrote
about seatbelts all had to do with the
fact that there's this guy named Leonard
Evans who used to work for GM for many
years who wrote this book called traffic
safety and the driver and traffic safety
driver if you are even remotely
interested in the subject of traffic
safety and I I strongly urge all of you
to become interested in this subject
you've got to read this book it is just
this kind of like everything you need to
know
about traffic safety I mean I read this
years ago and I call up Leonard Evans
who's this Scottish guy Christie Scott
Jersey Irish I think he's a Scottish guy
from Ireland is this wonderful accent
and he's just a delight so I've just
been corresponding with Leonard for
years emails and stuff I did some
stories at the Washington Post that were
prompted by work he'd done so I just
said to myself some point I would like
an excuse to hang out more with Leonard
so this story began as an excuse to hang
out more with Leonard um I'll tell what
Leonard Evans actually he gave me this
is the dumbest thing ever done of my
life
he said to me I wonder whether this has
been televised only to again trophyless
he said to me in 1992 he said Malcolm
you know what you should do you should
file a Freedom of Information Act
request with the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration and ask
them for all of the information they
have on injuries caused by airbags now
in 1992 the whole notion that an airbag
could injure somebody was not well known
it was a secret but there were these
files at Nitza where they had documented
all these people who had been killed by
airbags I did exactly what he said the
files came there was like four boxes of
them if you look through these files
they documented cases of people who've
been killed by airbags here's what I did
with those files nothing don't ask me
why I've no I have no explanation of
this it was a Pulitzer she was my plea
was my one moment it was like my chance
to be like famous Malcolm you know up
there with Bob Woodward and I blew it
all because I didn't listen to Leonard
so I've ruined my lesson and I went back
and I listened to him later one last
question so is there anyone that you
would have liked to have interviewed but
have not been successful in interview
yeah well because they've died yes um
when I did when I did my story on Ron
Popeil and I consider Ron I should say
to be the greatest single greatest
entrepreneurial mind in the Western
Hemisphere Ron Ron's father was SJ poppy
oh who invented the sly sematic and a
veg-o-matic and many other
a fisherman and he was this
extraordinary guy who you know his wife
tried to kill him and then he she went
to jail when she got a jail he remarried
her he he was you know he was obsessed
with he was just as kind of he was one
of these kind of old-school like self
created highly eccentric he lived you
know in those if you go in if you go to
Chicago and you go up Michigan Avenue
some of the miracles like all the
Miracle Mile whatever they're there they
up there's the Drake Hotel then those
beautiful apartments next the Drake
Hotel
well he had the penthouse and the Drake
and he had like I've chauffeured he had
one of the first car phones he would
call you in your car phone and he was
obsessed with like he'd wake up in the
middle of night and try and come up with
some new gadget to like you know fix
some non-existent problem and he was the
author of the what I consider to be the
greatest marketing line ever which was
when someone pointed out to him that the
pocket fisherman was not entirely a good
way of not a good fishing pole he said
it's not for using it's forgiving which
I just thought is anyway the more I read
about SJ and I interviewed all people
about SJ I was just filled with this
kind of overwhelming sadness that he had
died before I had the chance to kind of
and actually he had this patent lawyer
whose name escapes me who was just so
marvelous who was living in Florida and
he had been s J's patent lawyers entire
life and he just told me all these SJ
stories and the last one was that the
last thing about sheep appealed invented
and understand this is a man who
invented every one of the little gizmos
that people sold for the kitchen in the
period 1950 to 1970 was basically
invented by the last thing invented was
called the gondola and the gondola was
this unusual kind of pre-made pizza
crust that you could load with things
and esterday had retired in to Florida
and he was very old and the patent was
pending on the gondola and they've been
waiting many with all his complications
and then on the day that he got the vet
the lawyer called him to say the
come through s-type appealed died and if
you are inventor of gadgets there is no
more poetic way to pass from this earth
that then you know on the very day that
your last and perhaps most brilliant
creation is finally approved by the US
Patent Office and when you hear that you
just say how tragic that I couldn't have
written that story because it had it had
the perfect ending um anyway thank you
thank Malcolm Frank